the Joe Rogan experience do you get any
people upset that in some way you might
be glorifying violence maybe but I never
hear about it because I don't think
that's true I mean or if it is true it
doesn't I don't think it matters really
because it's fake it's not real right I
mean it's like I don't I don't think the
rules of real life apply to to art mmm I
just don't write because that's why art
exists just like you know that ages and
you just have to feel that way because
it's like okay well if we're gonna run
every movie through the PC filter then
in American History X Edward Norton
can't be racist sure you know how we
actually we don't have a movie or run
out you know Travis Bickle can't kill
anyone he just has to save Jodie Foster
because he's a nice person all right you
know yeah we're just have ruins
everything I mean but the rules of real
life are different but for fiction I
mean they can't be rules right and how
else are you going to depict these
absolutely possible scenarios like if
we're saying that there isn't suicidal
maniacs in real life like that's
nonsense so if you're allowed to make a
depiction of real life yeah of course
it's going to have to include racists
murderers Psychopaths every I just think
it's you know it's it's art and it can
go anywhere and it's always if it's
shocking that's probably good and it
won't be shocking next year like how
whatever you're showing your kids at one
point was shocking now they're like
seriously dad yeah we were talking about
jaws that yes jaws today apparently
would be PG it was PG then was it can
you believe that no yeah was it it was
oh my god it was just shocking
especially scared the [ __ ]
well that's because I bears took us to
see it which was awesome but I was
traumatized for sure yeah that was a
crazy movie I didn't want to have
anything to do with the water after that
movie yeah I still don't but the pets of
special effects as well man when that
shark rises out of the water for the
first time he always thrown the Chum in
the water man come on down here jump
some of this [ __ ] we're gonna need it
like it's hard to believe those lines
were like once just lines in a script
yeah I know they're iconic yeah they're
a part of culture now it's amazing yeah
[Applause]